now that jordan's gotten her talky
situation worked out uh we can let the
game
officially
get going here um we're back for another
exciting episode of spy fall this time
we have a an eclectic mix of
participants we've got uh ren wykman of
course hi i'm me
we've got matt karens hi i'm also me too
wait really
and of course we have and we we've
brought just for your trouton special
the battle of the jordans continues here
we've got jordan and jordan
uh and uh you know it's gonna be
interesting to see the dynamic there
yeah the battle will never be over what
are our nicknames
well in in the in the actual player chat
we've got
rent is due
so i'm going to guess that's you red yes
and then we have matt
i'm gonna guess that's matt
my nickname for matt is matt
it's already a nickname just one
technically i mean yeah actually you're
not right
but because you guys share a name you
have to have different names yes things
so it's important so you're jordy
literally no one has taken jordan which
is seems to defeat the purpose of
i can change both i can change too i
mean maybe that'll be a mind game for
her then
also jordan it's kind of kind of boring
if you just use your
your own yeah
we should get into it let's go
baby let's go let's go
before we start i just want to show off
i got a new guitar wow
obsidian it's made out of obsidian that
fell from the space
that's cool
uh lava so that it doesn't have time to
like form any sort of like crystal
structures so that's it come from the
space though it comes from the space
from the space underneath the ground
down space what kind of space
in world space
uh yeah we are playing spy fall today
and i'm very excited i have not played
spy fall on the podcast here so this is
the first for me i also haven't done it
either and jordan has never played yeah
this is a first for me oh dude george
jordan
and i haven't failed at lang before so i
feel like i'm really prepared
yeah this is gonna be an interesting one
strap in ladies and gentlemen yeah
jordan coleman's going to be an expert
this round all right um
let's go we got an eight-minute round
i've set it to outrageous locations so
if you're not familiar yeah jordan allen
uh just a rundown for you and everyone
else who's never played
spyfall a selection of locations are
given out and there is one person who is
the spy now the spy is the only person
who does not know the location okay and
the game works by each participant
asking a question to another participant
where that person then has to answer in
a way that tells the person who asked
the question that they also know the
location okay without giving it away so
that the spy figures it out if because
if the spy figures it out then the
game's over that's it
that's a wrap did you follow that yeah i
yeah well i knew the rules before so i
kind of zoned out but i feel you i feel
you a hundred percent and i'm ready
okay though so are you ready
it's pretty simple
um it's a lot of fun
and uh
let's just jump into it okay we've got
eight minute games set for outrageous
locations
here we go ready up and start round
toy factory
oh man we're starting i'm excited this
is gonna be great
okay
let's see
who is going to go first
is it should it's just
is it
it's supposed to be marked there's no
mark for me if i'm going first
okay
why don't i start and then we'll switch
to another app on the next game because
the other app has a better interface
than this okay yeah so clockwise dude i
mean look at these locations though
the butthole of a geriatric moose
what
my favorite place these are all these
are these locations
oh wait so these locations reference
real quick
are those those don't matter so these
are all potential places that we are
currently at they're all options if you
are the spy you don't know where we are
uh but everyone who's not the spy
sees it so yeah i see yeah well all
right so let me let me start with red
wren
yo
ren um
[Music]
would you have uh
enjoyed coming to this location um
more as an adult or as a child
i mean i think i would have enjoyed this
i don't
truthfully i wouldn't have enjoyed this
as a child but i don't think i'd enjoy
it as an adult either
interesting okay
uh
jc
hello hi jordan
um
did you park your car nearby
yes
yes
yes
yes my parents definitely did
unless they wanted to drag me across
a long long place
okay yep
okay
so
all right
wait
wait did i go no no no she's got to ask
a question
oh i see her she doesn't have to uh
ask someone new she could ask either me
or jake as well you can't you you can't
just can't you can't act back you
basically just leap frog yeah
okay okay
i'm gonna go with matt to give him an
extra yeah
um
matt what did what was like what would
you normally get from here like you know
your choice um
[Laughter]
an assortment of
some of my favorite things
you know as a child
yeah you guys are making it too easy
this is the toy factory i'm the spy oh
my goodness oh i must try not to go any
further than the child thing i can say
it's not my fault oh because you can't
see the other one yeah i have a list
here of all of the locations
i don't know where the location is well
we were in a shark cage so surprise
right
fine
wait you were in a shark cage no no it
was totally it was okay
i was trying to start it off easy
oh yeah i'm sure you were intentionally
started it off easy right all right fine
you know what let's go hard come on
let's get into it
all right back to the game oh i didn't
take a screencap
everyone
loaded it i
incredibly stressed in the corner click
ready if you're ready
those weren't as outrageous as they
should have been do you guys want to try
those are so fun
only
let's see what happens
those ones weren't
risque enough so let's let's read it
here we go round round two here we go
start
gun range
saucy
all right let's see these okay yeah
these these locations are more like it
okay
uh since i won last time should i go
first yeah why don't you why don't you
do the honors friend oh my gosh these
locations ren one everyone else zero
wow
okay
okay
jordy
jordy jordy jordy
speak to me
um
hmm how do i phrase this uh
did you bring your lunch
i honestly didn't think too
i don't like the wink at the end no i
tend to do that
[Music]
is
is this somewhere
your parents would bring you
they have they have before
really
interesting
yeah
okay
okay we're learning things
yeah sure i think he no no
jake okay i have a suspicion here let's
ask jake then oh you got a suspicion
wren no and that's not to do with hugh
jake
jake
how
how often would you say you go
to this place
well
me personally
i come i come to this place
about once a year
i know it's kind of weird but
all right is it weird i think i know who
the spy is
but i'm pretty sure i know who this
place is i like going
yeah do you like going
do you like going okay yeah
okay
i have no idea who this guy is you don't
all right riley
jordan coleman um hi
would you say that uh
well
can you give me a guess like how much
money do you typically spend
at this location
just just rough ballpark it
definitely
a few hundred
probably not less probably not less than
two hundred oh sorry guys is that
dollars
yeah not less than 200 from when i've
the freaking thing and my phone phone's
turned off
matt's headphones just died but
here's the plus side i think we all know
who the spy is
oh all right i'm voting for jc i think
she's the spy
wait wait you gathered that from
everyone else's interaction
i'm just i'm making a guess hey you know
what she hasn't even answered a question
yet hey i already know it's it's i mean
she didn't just she answered your
question wait wait but if he just said
so if i
if i
if i say the right place then i win
right
yes okay then wait
wait wait don't say the right place how
about this because if you say the right
person the sky is gonna hear
somebody getting your own phones so we
need to agree to guess or no i we can
also just like kind of [ __ ] talk you
know like we can throw out our own
guesses but we have to come to a
conclusion together to kick someone out
i see and i think we have enough data to
uh certify that to indict jordan coleman
is this awkward i would wonder do you
have enough data to guess
correctly why don't you ask another
question jordan we still have some time
yeah ask a question these are
interesting
today
i don't think it's i don't think it's
interesting today
in what state
would you think oh uh wren um what state
would you
say
people would like to go to this more if
you could just choose one taxes
am i still a spy one am i still the
spies
interesting
uh
okay uh
that's your answer ren is texas yes yeah
she asked what state
that i feel
what was the question it was like what
state would people go here more often
than other states
i think texas is a pretty safe yeah
maybe california
if someone's not if someone just
california is big so maybe
like how are we measuring this i was
trying to prove that i wasn't the spy
and he is that proven
is that proving that you're not
displaying
what is it really
i mean okay so in that case it makes me
wonder now uh
you're
all three of your guys's questions
answers
we're like just vague enough to be like
possibly lucky
so matt i think i think jake's a little
suspicious just just saying jake did say
once a year
yeah but that's the thing like i believe
that you think so i mean i only say that
that's the spy you don't think
come on
once a year all right okay you know what
jake i have another question for you
sure sh
hey ren
shoot
okay you're making it too easy now
i'm even more certain about my
choice uh
the
oh my dear god i just saw swingers
resort as an option for the locations
here sorry i got sidetracked wait are we
is that not where we are
once a year
that's what i said once a year oh that
also makes sense for the shooting thing
too yeah yeah thank you
jake
hey it's adult locations
do you leave with sore hands
from the swingers resort
don't we all right guys guys come on
it's it's the gun range i'm the spy
oh you're the spider
all right you were the spy wow i was i
was the spot i didn't pick it i think i
didn't pick it up until um you started
talking about texas
yeah dang i ruined it all i am
made you ruin it
but
but then they can just shoot outside
there okay the reason why so i asked how
often you go here and or someone asked
how often jake goes here that confirmed
for me that you were talking about the
gun range yeah that question that one
you're you being like hey he probably
goes more than once a year confirmed it
for me i was like oh okay the gun range
and he's like oh
because i pro i probably do go more than
once yeah i mean i was yeah i have gone
more than once a year this year dang
here i was thinking you probably only go
once a year because you got a big yard
that you probably just shoot in the
backyard like that's yes that's also
true and just i totally believed to my
core that you know what you're probably
telling the truth you probably do only
go to the gun range once a year
well i think that i think the thing
we're all still wondering is are your
hands sore
there you go
it depends on what you're shooting i
guess also i never go to the gun range
except for that one time we made a video
about it so spending two hundred dollars
blew me away i was like you spend 200
bucks every time you go to the gun range
oh yeah well
uh jordan an apology i'm sorry for
just
instantly thinking you're the spy yeah
i'm reducing the rounds to six minutes
the time right here
i'm all right so
ren's gotta win i've gotta win there's
no wins for the for the normies yet only
for the spies
wow although i feel like i should give
up my one considering how badly i just
hey can we can we also there's a little
there's a little thing underneath your
location that says what uh
your role is at the location can we can
we play that a little bit more oh yeah
role play yeah yeah i need new home
phones cause these keep going
i got you that's why i brought them down
here even though they were at full
battery
yeah all right
this is so hard
i won the last round so yeah right can
we pause this
no no no pausing the podcast matt no
never ever it's amazing that we can do
that all right i won the last round so
here we go
um
whoa just slipping in here to let you
know that today's episode is brought to
you by manscaped now if you guys don't
know what manscaped does they make
premiere tools for your groin and body
trimming with their new lawnmower 4.0
trimmer you're going to get the best
shave down there that you can get this
fourth generation trimmer that features
a cutting edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents thanks to their
advanced skin safe technology this
upgraded trimmer includes a
multi-function on off switch that can
engage in a travel lock if you're on the
go and it also gives you the ability to
turn on a 4000k led light to help you
get a little bit better visibility in
those hard-to-see hard-to-reach places
maybe you're one of those people who
like to get creative down there well
guess what the lawnmower 4.0 has
trimming guards so you can customize
your look down there it also has a
convenient wireless charger so once
you're done with it you can go ahead
throw it back on the wireless charger
and it'll be ready for you next time you
need it maybe you're one of those people
who trims every day maybe you're
i don't know i don't care don't tell me
i don't want to know just do you so if
you're interested in getting 20 off and
free shipping on this amazing technology
that's actually built to do the job you
need it to do click the link in the
description below and use the code
corridor cast 20 to get 20 off and free
shipping all right so there you have it
now let's get back to the podcast
yoga class
hey man uh
i'm just here
i'm just here you're laughing at i can't
hear him
what i'm looking to do at this location
is uh
really um
well
it's about
taking care of yourself
okay now i'm gonna get back in this and
others
all right um
i should be back
jake can you talk for me
hello
okay hi okay cool he's in our boys
returned matt is in jake uh you start
playing a character but you haven't
asked anyone a question
that's right i realized that sometimes i
forget because you know i'm just who i
am so anyways jordan jordan allen
hey man speak to me
hey uh
so
do you typically stay overnight at this
location or is it more of like a
you know
short-term stay
you know
personally i'm there longer than most
but
the average stay
is quite short
interesting playing that character
it's a jordan squared question okay
cuz that was yeah i know okay here i
just my turn
i did forget that part that's why i was
sitting here silently
okay
i'm going to go to matt matt has not
faced me once so far he's just side eyed
me so
we're going to dig a little deeper dude
the side eye
do you feel
better or worse once you've been here
after after i leave
yeah of course of course
almost always
which one is this one yes yes almost
always are you talking about the plastic
surgeons again
no
wait no jake
oh sauce
okay so jake wait hold on yes what are
you doing okay what
what are you up to
i'm just here
at the location with you guys
yeah you are yeah
what do you
what do you mean
no no further questions
i don't know that was that was a little
bit different
one of the strangest moments of my life
what that means like
he just name dropped a location
well i
i potentially i would hope that you
probably i would hope you would feel it
better eventually after leaving the
plastic surgeon okay okay jake i got a
question for you
check the spot
before you don't give it away don't
freaking fire off accusations randomly
okay we gotta get to the bottom of this
i'm gonna ask you a question dude guilty
until proverbial
chill why don't you chill out for a
second all right let me ask you this
jake whoa how much do you typically
spend at this location when you go here
well
it's
like
it's hard for me to depend on if you
have insurance i don't want to give it
away
but
it's kind of a
per experience thing for me okay per
experience
uh yeah
i feel that that's a cop out of an
answer if i've ever heard it is it
really is per experience
yeah you pay per experience
um
yeah okay
i mean i agree with that
i do agree with you all right jake ask a
question
all right jordan coleman
hello
i'm in character by the way do you
[Music]
would you go here
while you're on vacation or would you go
here for a vacation
run
what do you want me to do it or do you
oh my god i think you
you want to do it shall we raise a vote
listen i listen guys it's definitely not
me i was playing
facetious or you know
whatever you want to call it raise it
because because whenever you do your
house
typically when you do this when you play
this way whoever is the spy
will immediately raise their hand
and call
for the for the vote of somebody else
okay yeah but in this
specifically in this specific instance
first of all you've got your legacy
and we've got ren you literally just
name dropped another book it looks like
it's official jake it's over we've voted
i think it's jordan allen is it wow that
was terrible wren actually i'm not
spying i told you
i told you
i was trying to get and yeah
also
just
hold on let me go back let me just do a
quick analysis of what just happened
there
ren ren got all up and up in arms about
going on a witch hunt
and then the person who's actually the
spy jumped on the bandwagon behind him
you got it exactly i was literally just
telling you about the time we're playing
among us when i killed you and dean
instantly thought it was niko
instead of me and i instantly was like
oh dean i think you're right yeah dude
just gotta be nico
you literally just
gave that back to me that's exactly what
happened the thing is well played on
your part thank you ren was the front
man too so like if anyone was going down
it would have been him not me yeah
because he was the first one to you're
just the perfect player he gave me the
perfect dog
i knew it was you matt
i knew that side eye i felt it in the
side eye the side eye i know your eyes i
know when you're lying what was the
location was yoga class oh okay
i was just a humble hippie man okay
oh wow that actually makes sense to me
but yeah i was literally saying namaste
to signal to you that it wasn't me i
remember that entire experience
yeah he said her experience for the yoga
class which is the same price every time
you go i made a big money
yeah but then sometimes it's donation
like like the west side come on you can
go out for free class there's a concert
house it's variable every week
good night
though jake i like it it didn't work
this time for you it really got fired
i did enjoy the panic to namaste's
though that was enjoyable
i didn't hear you say that how did i not
do that all right get ready y'all
all right here we go because i thought
you just got lucky with the
the the accent and the character at
first because at first i was like oh
yeah no you're definitely in but then
you you tricked me
hey welcome to the party yacht
all right well matt you won the round so
you do the honors
okay
um
jc where am i hi how are you i'm good
how are you we're both at this location
together obviously correct
um what what
type of like social class are you at
this location
[Music]
okay i would say
medium to high
medium to high
well well well
indeed yes okay okay okay okay alan
yes
alan
what would you say i'm just so stern
[Laughter]
what would you be consuming food wise
here
hmm
i must be wise here
dang jordan's a spy jordan's a spy
namaste
[Laughter]
we're going to vote you off the island
that for the record that was a joke
now i'm scared
[Music]
whatever's there one bite at a time i
asked what kind of food you consume
one bite that's his answer you know he
can answer however he wants that
that's a great answer thank you i just
want to say
you know
i i don't even know why i'm here
to be honest jake why are you talking
you're not you're not no one asks you
anything um listen i'm just i'm just
chipping in i'm just playing the role
what's your
oh i have the question now right yeah i
have the floor yeah yeah you gotta ask
yeah okay
yeah run let's chat all right all right
oh a celebrity
who is it
i'm you're gonna vote me out already uh
okay uh sorry sorry i uh
i was nauseous
um
i i apologize for getting mama all over
that celebrity
oh
i also like that celebrity
is this the rehab clinic we got a
celebrity and a
and what sounds like a sick person
nice
can i actually say that with confidence
now yeah but i'm afraid to
i'm joking
what god dang it
wait
red this is a mind game yeah but you're
throwing out the weirdest mind game
retorts
i'm so confused yeah me too i'm i think
i'm ruining it i'm sorry
you have the floor now though you can
throw jake something special
uh
we ran out of beer would you be down to
go
down the street to the store to pick up
beer for us
the store
is quite a ways from here red
quite a ways
okay
i'm gonna have to charge you a
premium
it's gonna involve freight
okay uh
and uh you're gonna i can do it because
i am one of the only sober people here
but
it's gonna cost you so are if you're
willing to pay for it i'll do it
okay
hmm
dang okay yeah
all
right
see jake keeps trying to throw everyone
by like name dropping uh other ref like
other locations okay yeah just meta game
here is that you're
well just a rule thing are you able to
fake guess
i mean i'm not fake guessing i'm like
it looks like you're fake guessing yeah
i thought you were guessing earlier when
you did that well i was yeah even
christian did that was just bantering i
guess i'll stop doing that i've been
there
they dropped it actually like that i was
like oh yeah like wait that was the
question
for
for jordan coleman hello
what is it exactly you'd say
you do here
well
i guess it depends
i'm helping people
you're helping people people helping
people i'm helping i'm just hopping
helping out sounds like the rehab clinic
am i right jake that's why i said that
because it's a joke
it's a good joke that's why i use it
again
i'm not used to
people playing with throwing out
locations before they're ready i'm not
gonna do it i was just the gotcha yeah
yeah don't worry about it
it could be the rehab clinic though i'm
just saying
good
lord right jordan you're trying to ask
jordan allen a question i think it's him
jake is so i've been killed
all the time
wait oh the game just ended
okay you got let's last question last
question
what are you wearing
who are you wearing
who are you wearing
i am wearing
black on the bottoms
let me let me paint you a picture you
said that was something black on the
bottoms
shine of shoes
okay
nice top and something tied tight around
my neck
are you gonna hang yourself it does kind
of sound like this
the round has ended wow i have no idea
i have absolutely no idea
i mean i'll i'll throw out a name
which makes me sound suspicious so no i
won't okay someone else do it no no you
started you gotta finish okay
i'm feeling jake i'm i'm feeling jake
honestly i'm feeling are we gonna do
this again with jake
well he wasn't this guy last time he
could have been this time honestly i
don't know i don't know at all
first question matt asked the first
question to jordan upon which he
obtained information but no one's ever
actually asked him a question oh
but the game's over but guess what
jake's turning it around
because maybe he's
saying
i will say that matt's only real comment
was a copy of jake listen guys one of my
favorite songs y'all are destroying
yourself you're really really really
really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really
really
really
really
really really really really really really good
asked about the meta question about like
as fake asking
locations and then he did exactly that
you're gonna regret your decision if you
do this i'm gonna vote i'm vote matt let
me say this before you do your vote the
rest of your votes you can vote whatever
you want um
i will the first question i just asked
was about class
social class think about that if you
know the location this is why i think
about how that matters that was why i
didn't suspect it's either that's why i
said it's either you or ren but jordan
did respond with medium to high and then
asked what kind of food do you eat
honestly guys jordan has been asking
some very vague questions that's a very
good thing
medium to high doesn't work for you
let's clear this up jordan have you ever
lied
excuse you have you ever lied just in
general
yeah she doesn't have to answer it the
game's over i mean we got a vote and
she's lying she's a liar i'm going
jordan i'm going jordan too i am as well
that i
i'm the spot sorry guys i can't are you
oh so they got her
oh
i got it for you
okay she has one chance to reduce
with the freaking private jet um
so you eating there is weird yeah well
the hors d'oeuvres one bite at a time
the thing around my neck was a bow tie
just to be clear
yes
not interested
[Laughter]
run it back run it back
ready
all right let's do this all right man
this is great i turned that around yeah
that was well it was gonna be me yeah
yeah you definitely reminded me yeah oh
no the very first thing you said
instantly uh made me not suspect it's a
weird thing though
it feels like on the whole the more you
talk the more suspicious you sound right
round four here we go
the red light district we've got
everything you need
what kind of classic people go here well
done
oh boy okay
alrighty this is going to be
fun round for me oh boy all right
remember
hone in to
what they say you are lock in
on me lock it in you here
i'm here i hear it
all right
jake
jake
what's going on
all right i thought you heard me
what's going on
if you had to
sorry
i don't even you're such an embarrassing
person
maybe maybe
what kind of coat you got on
my coat
yeah
i heard you
usually the coat
that i have on
is
really
first it's for someone else
you know i get i give it away
okay
i like that i like it
uh
you gave away a coat
yeah i give away my coat i'm classy like
that but you know okay okay all right
okay
all right um red i can get behind yeah
what up joker
ran um
joker
do you know what kind of
uh what kind of
intoxicants i might be able to
find
at this location
um
what kind of
intoxicants
that's right come from within
here
they're euphoric
oh euphoric intoxicants
wow okay
they come from within
yeah
all right the intoxicant okay i guess if
that's what you uh
matt
yeah hey you're at this location with me
uh i'm got a question for you
i'm
i'm lost
and i'm trying to get somewhere specific
i'm just me i'm
uh how
hmm
can you hurry it up
should we just vote for redneck i got
stuck
should i take a right
at the at the stop sign or left at the
stoplight
left at the stoplight
well
who are you asking
i was asking matt
okay
and he answered
okay i don't really know where that
where that's going to get you
but i answered
your question
i'm voting for red
i'm going to vote
um what uh
how much how much how much
like product do you move here usually
like i'm if you're
i just snotted here i move all of it
all the product
what
all the products all the products all
right
maybe maybe
maybe you know you kind of got it right
yeah you got two
you got two in this
in this location that we're at yeah you
kind of have to you kind of move there's
a lot of product maybe
you think
well it depends
yeah
what does it depend on
how much product you got oh true you
know what i mean
so is this more like a stash house or is
it like a trap house no no wait are you
asking a question jake no i'm just
answering what kind of question does
that sound like i don't know
we're in a position to be answering
questions right now um
uh
alan
so it's my turn to ask it's your turn to
ask another question yes or ask a
question
okay
what time of day will you find yourself
here you're asking are you asking jc oh
hi um
well me personally
uh
i started a little earlier than some
people because i gotta get some money
but uh
yeah you follow me around sun sun down
sun down to maybe sunrise okay
thank you
yeah thank you thank you for your time
thank you very much of course of course
come back come back here come back i'll
be dropping you allen is the
yeah
it's either jordan allen or it's red
let's make a decision here
uh oh
i think i think i i think ren has
convinced me the moment you choose me
i think it's jordan allen and i think i
think he thinks wait what did i say
not a lot
not a lot i think i did if you know
where you're at
that's exactly what every spy says not
know if you know
if you know you know okay although to be
fair jake has been throwing out most of
the accusations here yeah bait and
switch why don't you ask him a question
yeah we got well what was the last
question
you know i'm you know why i'm throwing
out accusations because you guys don't
understand my role i mean i just went i
could ask i'm gonna ask a question i
could i could i could do this that's why
all right why don't you do it wait who
what was the last answer that jake gave
all right you've got one minute
oh you know when you uh when you leave i
would like to know because i what i do
jake uh you leave happy or satisfied um
how are you
how you feel jake i don't leave happy
but i leave him satisfied and you
definitely know what i'm talking about
because at the end of the at in the
morning oh somehow yeah you always end
up with a piece of my pie oh okay
man oh man that's what you meant by give
away your jacket man that's right okay
so now jordan allen is my vote
um i get i'm almost done that's a
mistake
tell us why it's not you uh i mean i'm
gonna vote jordan oh yeah
dang i'm not sure i mean you gave the
vegas quest answers
you don't want to do that i know i don't
i have no confidence in my selection
abilities right now so
namaste
it's jordan allen is this okay
you answered it with one second to spare
damn
oh i was trying to hold on to that one
jesus
you guys don't move the product do you
know what i mean
at first he thought at first you thought
we were at the meth house didn't you
no no i thought when i answered that
question i knew red light district
already but i was just securing my place
amongst the normies i was i was really
trying to get like whoever was the spy
to think it was the meth house yeah with
the product thing wait what was your
role i was the pimp yes i got that yeah
i got that right away because i'm the i
was the prostitute yeah yes
i thought you were at first when you're
like i gave away my jack and i was like
thinking way too literally i thought it
was the cocktail party at that point
giving away the jacket i was like okay
maybe he's like taking it
i mean i
i was trying to go for like a high-class
male prostitute you know so that's why i
started with like the i like that
prostitution is what i associate with
red light districts so all the drug talk
really confused me i'll tell you what
what what gave me the answer was wren's
question about the stoplight red light
that was a little too on the news yeah i
was looking through and i was like none
of these make any sense except for red
light yeah district oh
i panicked a little bit once i realized
you guys were like thinking it was me i
was like
i gotta solidify this answer and make it
a little too obvious oh there's the
balance there's a delicate balance
should we do one more
yeah yeah yeah i'm the only one yeah
let's do it all right let's do it
hey bro we're in the locker room
all right so have
wait have the have you
have the non spies one
at all yet yeah there's one
we
and only because she admitted she was
the spy before i had voted yeah that was
that was helpful
thank
spies are winning you
all right let's go come on come on
normies let's go
all right
ready
here we go
oh yeah so do i go first yep you go
first
challenge accepted hmm
i think jake's the spy
let's take a vote
damn
the look on your face
[Music]
you're like
okay
i'm gonna uh i'm gonna shoot my question
to matt
what's up bro
hello
um
you see anything you like in here
[Laughter]
oh yeah i do brother
i got all kinds of stuff i like in here
nice i mean some of this is designated
just for me
yikes
thank you
[Laughter]
brother see on the quad later
nice
you guys are too easy this is the
freaking fraternity house and i'm the
spy
oh
i had like a cartoon little like snare
trap
with the ropes and just a little piece
of bait
and i was a college athlete so it still
totally fits my character yeah and i was
a middle-aged person
all right i'm the celebrity so this is
obviously like equinox
for real i'm a celebrity in this gym
now it makes sense why jake was so
instantly offended when i made that joke
because i accidentally was
correct okay that was a quick round we
got yeah we got to do it
one more oh that was so satisfying wow
that was beautiful
someone's so confident yeah he just knew
yeah for a moment there i thought it was
like game over i was like oh man
but it was perfect
he laid the perfect trap well both are
both like perfect
all right here we go here we go round
seven never again
welcome to the meth lab
never forget guys remember
okay okay
okay
okay
all right
all right well uh
jordan island is high for
okay
jake take us away all right all right
ah
start with alan
matt
yo what's up buddy
hey
um i'll take some of what you have
okay
yeah is that a question you got the uh
you got the dough for it
you guys are got the cheddar
stupid
uh well not not not not here
um
close by
okay
okay so so if
my question is would you make a deal
with me
i'll make a i'll make a deal with you if
you're uh
if you're cool if we're cool
yeah
okay
capital c
capital c for cool is what your name is
now
um askren hmm
ask around well i'm going to ask jordan
no i didn't all right
um uh
what do uh
what what what exactly are you um
looking for here at this location what
do you mean i'm not gonna do that i'm
gonna do with my voice
[Laughter]
is there something specific is there
something that i'm looking for something
that you're kind of like looking forward
like
i don't look for anything
people look for me
people look for you people look for me
okay
i was going to do another accent and
then again i just i don't know what i'm
doing out here
but my question my question's coming yes
let's hear it right to wren
i'm gonna give you that side eye have
you
hurt my ass ever been here
before
i look at this place all the time
can't do much about it
but i try
i did forget we're playing characters
which completely deflated my question
okay great
awesome
all right ren
jc
hello
my character
cool no
would you say the
oh my oh
jen doesn't even care if we're doing a
podcast
oh and then you're out of ammo what are
you going to do
all of us get the dart i'm getting him
this is devastating
we're not in the game
oh thank god
i get to keep this we just got my chance
this is my souvenir
makes an entrance mid-game
he's
always playing the game
that was terrifying yep it's a game
within a game oh wow
come on look
would you say come on let's get this
going yeah yeah so jc um
would you say the issues here are pretty
cut and dry or black and white
i i would say cut and dry cut and dry um
[Laughter]
do you need to go to the hospital i hope
it's cut and i hope it's dry yes
okay okay i i see i see your character i
see your character hmm
i mean i mean kinda
kinda
jordan ask a question i don't like the
look in his eyes
he's gotta ask matt he's got wild eyes
yeah what's up asked has jason asked
how's drinking i've i've been asked
tricks well matt hasn't been asked that
mata
matt asked the first question matt i did
what are you wet what are you wearing
what are you what are you personally
wearing uh one of my personally
inside um of this location okay well
what are you wearing inside this i don't
like to get my hands dirty
i don't like to get my hands dirty so
typically
i have a nice soup okay but
sometimes
i work out okay i like it
love it
certain places oh okay
certain types of coats are necessary for
oh i agree i agree okay no further
questions interesting ask ask away i
mean that
that one
yeah matt's answer there makes total
sense to me yes
why matt why don't you ask a question
man why
why don't i ask a question yeah maybe
ask jordan allen a question i'm just i'm
so suspicious of ren i don't know what
it is he has he has supported people's
answers while being vague yeah
while being vague yes
okay um
all right oh you know what i will answer
your question in a way that you know
that i know okay okay
um
oh god i apologize i apologize to any
spy here i like that you can tell
how
what what this operation is like
is it legal
absolutely not but it's hard to prove
sometimes
it's good i like this guy i'll keep this
guy around
we've been working on it for a while
but
yeah sometimes
our
[Music]
it's not you know it's not ren
cool uh i'm the spy and the location is
counterfeit market oh no
it's not no it's not no
okay oh no you have to guess try guys
just yes
okay yeah he's he's done oh what a
thrill
you lost i did okay
i'm the undercover cop at the meth lab
and you're going to jail yeah that's
right i'm the chemist by the way i'm a
kingpin i wouldn't have guessed it was
you though which is interesting because
of the way that you said like oh yeah
that makes sense i instantly pretty
clever yeah yeah yes it was
in the meth lab
i honestly didn't even see that option
here
i looked over it so many times
cut and dry was a good one cut and dry
was good see i thought it was
counterfeit markus when i said black and
white i was alluding to black market
i wouldn't have even probably gotten
that
yes okay very good things
yeah no i was playing as the fbi agent
and i'm the chemist i was like yes cut
and dried yeah i would like a cut and
dress yeah i knew you were the i knew
you were the uh chemist
yeah for sure yeah
yeah that was painfully obvious
meanwhile i'm over here being like are
you the fruit vendor are you chopping up
all of the vegetables for people like
that i see that at the night market but
not the last market round
oh my gosh oh here we
as if all the other rounds didn't matter
at all
it says it's as if
no other round mattered
you could just skip to this round as if
all right and here
we
go dance
so exciting
and we're back on the party yacht
nope
[Music]
are you still a cop should we do a
different one
no
no
okay
no we're going with it oh this is what
this is this is the way the chips so
because i lost should i ask a question
then
jay allen is definitely the spy i mean i
was inspired last time
jay allen is most 100 chase okay you're
throwing a lot of heat right out the
gate yeah very suspicious um the way
that he reacted when uh why don't you uh
jay allen oh
you took the bait
take the bait
i i have some initial suspicions
and
suspicions about who is innocent
so
the game
jay allen hmm
i lost my question i uh one moment
i know ask him if he agrees if we should
do a different one
that's what i'm trying
[Laughter]
do you want to uh
i left my my keys in the car uh
can you go grab them for me i'm busy
working right now
no
that was a bad question you're right
that was a shitty question
[Laughter]
yeah great question starting it off all
right all right yep all right all right
okay
okay um
no
i have a question i'm sure but i feel
like the answer will be too obvious
so it sounds like something spy would
say
if you know you know
if you know you know you know namaste
namaste
um
look down
what is in your hand matt
what's in my hand
what's inside my hand unbelievable
oh well i have um
this class and it's
almost empty
and
someone should fill it up pretty soon
alan that'll be pretty simple i'll fill
that up soon huh why don't you fill that
glass up
it's like i'm there
it's
magical
let's get let's ask someone else a quick
question that yeah with an answer of no
so we can ask jordan allen another
question again yeah yeah i i would
actually fully support a naughty boy
at this location get that going
a naughty boy are you a naughty
are you naughty
[Music]
how do i answer that one
how do you
i
am not naughty but everything
around me is no
hot that's pretty hot
i got my hands on this thing so no one
dies
what i got ah
that's that's pretty naughty go ahead
i'm leading us into the naughty
area it's a very
uh
uh
we're
nasty
uh please ask please ask jordan allen
another i'm asking jordan ellen
um
did you
how much did you pay for the admission
ticket
me personally yes
i mean how much i'm actually being paid
got things oh
i'm dang it man
again that was another bad questions in
the wrong basket
that was an easy one i work here where
the meg's going now jc has just
literally just been squinting and
looking at me the whole time
has not participated just like the
highlight out
well no i was paid to be here so i'm
going to
so
so he won't he's namaste
that's great all right um
[Music]
where are we going
i believe that we're going
north
wow
i'm dissatisfied
do you not like that answer i don't like
that this i thought was going to be easy
and it's getting less easy yeah
satisfied
okay
jordan
hi jake
jake has not been asked a question
i have not been asked a question but
i've been here the whole time
um
i think my kid is building
sand castles on the beach
but yeah like i totally forgot to like
go put sunscreen on him would you mind
doing can you can you go put sunscreen
sure no
yeah
i come here every day so yeah i'll do
that yeah
too many words too many words too many
words
voting yeah
all right jake what you guess
fine i am the spy
i still get it i still get a shot
yeah you do go for it and it's we're out
we're
we're either i'm gonna i'm gonna say
what i think it is and then i'm gonna go
nobody
we're either at the swingers resort
or
we're at the nude beach
my guess is we're at the nude beach
feel free to guess the other one as well
try yeah
we'll give you one more guess
so it's neither of those
yeah you've already lost but yeah
you can get both of your guesses and
we'll still win
really
oh no
so the reason why i right away was like
let's do a different one is because it
was uh once again the party
and now it makes sense right away jake
was like no
you know what fine we'll do it again
yeah all right all right shoot
wow so genuinely instantly oh my my
suspicion because i was like kids on the
beach he's acknowledging that yeah that
was good
that was good first i was like
oh yeah it was that last sentence
yeah
it was the
that's way worse
i thought we were at a nude beach that's
the way i was playing it okay i was
playing i was playing a retiree at a
nude beach oh nice
yeah you're having sunscreen on
travelers
[Laughter]
you didn't want to say no to that
listen well
i wouldn't have i wouldn't put my kid
out there i'll tell you that much
well that was a lot of fun that was fun
it was a hoot that was a little oh yeah
real quick it was another yeah another
introduction to spy fall for some of you
another experience for many of you dude
i i with my quick victory right out of
the gate gave me so much false
confidence yeah
oh yeah
like every thought i have is correct
i
understand the salem witch trials so
much better knowing wren
i got pulled right in i just grabbed my
pitchfork
ren walked into a casino
went to the roulette table put a hundred
on the number 15
hit it and then thought he knew how to
play roulette yeah
yes
amazing did you keep winning
every time every time yeah he's still in
his mind he's still still winning i
haven't played uh spyfall in a while
that was fun yeah that was fair
and thanks for listening and watching
everyone yeah and if you have any um
interesting new locations that are
available please let us know uh we'll
definitely hit them up i like playing
the
the adults only the adults only zone
this was so much fun saucy dang i
thought i had it with the freaking
market you really did didn't you there
was a shark tank on there as soon as you
said that
matt as soon as you said bro i i was
convinced we were at the free party
i figured you would be
dangerous
oh yeah by the way guys
the video version of this podcast is now
on spotify that is the thing now and we
are doing it oh you're saying that
now yep you're on there
you can watch the videos on both youtube
and
spotify what if there was a fan of the
podcast that didn't watch any of our
corridor videos and had no idea what we
looked like and now they're like oh wow
we're just devastated
can we do this
can we do this right now if you stumbled
across this podcast and you have no idea
about corridor crew or corridor digital
please do not
watch them
do not watch those channels and start
documenting
your experience as a list as a only
listener to the corridor cast
and then in a year from now come to us
with all of your data and show us what
your experience was like
and how we're gonna make a movie about
it yeah we'd love
whatever their character traits are
their character bible all of that we're
going to do a movie just based off of
what we're looking at
from an outside perspective that has no
context
it turns out this person is actually
just daniel
he has been daniel the whole time
oh man
he like never watches his own videos he
just makes them based on the podcast
yeah
all right anyways thanks for listening
everybody until next week um we'll see
you right back here the corridor all
right
bye-bye bye
three two one